la plateforme méphisto commune à
plusieurs laboratoires à besançon et
belfort
ce sont 400 m² dédiés à la recherche
l'expérimentation et l'innovation
ici on peut usines et l'infiniment petit
analyser l'intérieur de pièces
minuscules mettre au point de nouveaux
process réaliser des composants grâce à
une impression 3d des équipements très
pointues pour préparer demain nous
faisons de la recherche qui est
fortement impliqué et qui peut être
transféré notamment à la formation nos
élèves comme vous pouvez le voir ici
pour qui s'accaparent c'est
technologique et puis s'est diffusé dans
l'entreprise mais également aux
industriels pour leur dire eh bien
écoutez vous avez pas très loin de chez
vous des moyens d'apprendre les nouveaux
savoir-faire ou de répondre à des
thématiques sur lesquelles vous ne savez
pas répondre venez à moi vous aider les
étudiants peuvent mener leurs projets de
la conception à la réalisation
ils ont les équipements de la plate
forme à leur disposition une utilisation
qu'ils pourront valoriser sur leur cv à
l'issue de leurs études
vous voulez plus quand on a accès à ce
genre de matériel c'est qu'on découvre
beaucoup de procéder notamment ici sur
une machine fraisage cinq axes grâce à
cette machine on a pu concevoir et
fabriquer un micro ballon de 8 mm de
diamètre qui par la suite sera plus
petit pour l'intégrer dans une montre
suisse donc d'un très grand horloger
l'horlogerie le début de l'histoire des
microtechniques en franche comté qui se
décline aujourd'hui dans de nombreux
domaines luxe automobile connectique
santé ou aéronautique
autant de secteurs qui vont pouvoir
s'appuyer sur cette plateforme
l'intérêt c'est de ne pas déconnecter
des besoins industriels de l'économie
réelle de la région donc on est en plein
coeur de la microtechnique de la
micromécanique qui on voit que vu le
nombre de sollicitations
on commence à être connu et c'est un
besoin essentiel pour les entreprises
recherche formation et développement
économique
la plateforme unique en france joue sur
les trois tableaux
[Musique]